ガチャン
ガタガタw
ははははははっ
あああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああwwww
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
今日のツイッター
さむいでええええええええええすう
そうですねぇ
俺なんて今日も一日
サンダルさ
今ですね、たくみくんが僕の家に来ております。
皆さんこういう商品知ってるでしょうか。
レシート貼ってて申し訳ないんですが、
鳥のうんちシールっていうやつがあります。
めっちゃリアルじゃね？っていうレベルでめちゃくちゃリアル。
これどういう使い道があるかというと
ただのいたずらグッズではなくて、(結局いたずら）
あのーちゃんと実用的な物になっています。
裏を見てみましょう。
チャリってパクられないすか？
なんか椅子だけパクられるっていういうそういうずらがよくあると思うんですけども
これね、
自転車の椅子とかにはルシールです。
そーするともら皆なんか
鳥のふんなんかついてる自転車なんか盗みたくないじゃん？
だからこのシールを貼ることによって、
あの、盗難の確率が大幅に下がるんだよ
みたいな感じらしいです。
これでも自転車が守れるみたいな
要するに防犯グッツの一つになっています。
ということは！
この防犯グッツ
自転車じゃなくて、
車にもつかえるんじゃね？
そう思った僕は
彼が家の中にいる間に、
彼の車に
上のうんちシールを
大量に貼ってみることにした。
こうすることによって
彼の車がとても汚く見えて
彼の車が盗まれる確率が大幅に減る
泥棒さんも鳥のふんが
沢山落ちてる車なんて盗みたいと思わないんで
こうすることで防犯のレベルをあげてぇ
彼の車の盗難の確率を大幅に下げてあげようと言う
なんとも優しい企画になっております。
ではやっていきましょう（歯にノリがついてる）
（はじめ入場www）
え
ファン？：はじめしゃちょーさんですか
完全に鳥のふんですね
それもリアルなやつww
はい、バッチリです。
これで多分彼の車が盗まれる心配はないでしょう。。
後は本人の反応を待ってみましょうw
ではｗ
ターゲットw
ポン！
マジ！？（マジです）
ええ～x2（泣
行っちゃうんかーいwww
♪とりとりフンフンとりとりフンフン
♪とーーーりのフンーのーーーシールをーーーはったけーどーー
♪結局ー反応ーはーなかーーぁったーよー
♪シールをはったの、意味無し！
ハッハハハハハハ★（奇妙）
（今までの時間全部無駄にした。コンチキショー！）
（あーもう！！）